Hi, I'm Merrin from The Small Business Geeks and I'm gonna show you some technical tips...
...and how to present yourself on video.
Technical Tip: Audio.
If you're wearing a microphone, make sure that you don't play around with it...
...and be real mindful of things like jewelry that will be very distracting if, for some reason,...
...they knock against the microphone.
Presentation Tip: Use language that everyone can understand.
Simple words, nothing too long, nothing too big unless that's your specific target audience.
For example, a doctor might need to use technical terms but otherwise keep it simple,...
...don't use too much slang.
Well, hopefully you find those tips helpful.